- Sofia.
- [Sofia] Hi.
- Hi, I heard you have
an imaginary friend.
- I do, I do have one, I do
have an imaginary friend, yes.
(quiet music)
She was a deer named Erin.
And we had a plant in like a
house plant in our apartment
when I was a kid and I used
to dig up, like the roots
of this plant and
immediately blame it on Erin.
And my parents like couldn't
do anything about it
'cause they were like,
"We have to let her have
her imaginary friend."
I think in my mind she was
like Bambi's mom or sister
you know what I mean?
I was like really upset when
Bambi's mom died as a kid.
So I had like a connection to
like a female maternal deer.
Definitely used her as a
scapegoat, like a hundred percent.
- Hi.
- You had an imaginary friend as a kid?
- I did.
- [Interviewer] Or even
til this day? (chuckles)
- [Voiceover] Pete was a human.
I was a very literal kid, so
Pete was basically like my,
sort of obnoxious little brother.
I was the good kid and
Pete was the one who
like set things on fire.
Pete and I hung out a lot.
I liked playing him in checkers,
he was better at me in checkers.
And I realized quickly
that when you play yourself
in checkers the person who goes
second kind of always wins.
- [Interviewer] Quanta.
- Oh hey, what's up?
- [Interviewer] Hi.
Do you wanna talk about
your imaginary friend?
- Uh sure, yeah.
So I had like a few
imaginary friends growing up.
One that was probably my
favorite was my friend Ralph.
He had like a round face
and he had like curly hair
and I think he was always wearing
like a blue shirt for some reason.
He was cool.
We would play games together.
We actually plotted one time,
so I had like, I loved the Rugrats.
Obviously everyone knew
that Angelica was evil.
So we plotted to
(chuckles) kidnap Angelica.
He made me do this.
But we duct taped her hands together
and duct taped her mouth.
My mom told me I was like cursing at it,
but it was Ralph that
was cursing at Angelica.
He really was like,
kind of a violent person
and kind of influenced me
to do crazy stuff like that.
But he was, he was great.
- Britney Ashley.
This is your song.
Um, I heard you had an imaginary friend.
- [Britney Ashley] I had more than
just one imaginary friend.
I had a whole entire
imaginary baseball team.
Every day after school when
I was in elementary school,
I had a huge backyard and I would play,
I would, you know curate
my own baseball practice
to my whole invisible baseball team.
They had names, it was generally,
this is very sad, it was generally names,
like kids names that I
wanted to name my children.
It was a lot unisex names.
It was great.
I'm insane now.
- (chuckles) My imaginarys
friend's name was Dakota.
Dakota was a bull.
He was orange.
Dakota was a little bit of
everything when I was growing up.
He was a cowboy obviously,
Samurai, a ninja,
he was a paleontologist for a little bit.
Yeah, but it wasn't like a bad influence.
He was basically when
my friends couldn't play
and I had to entertain myself.
Me and Dakota went on adventures.
He's probably a jet fighter now.
'Cause that seems like
it would be really fun.
But you put away childish things
and you become a boring adult.
And Dakota is someone else's now.
(quiet music)